she had been suffering terribly just so
unfair
she started my family it was it was I
was in the middle of the night and it
was race to get there it was a very
powerful experience and then in her last
moments she was at peace it's rare
someone can speak so eloquently after
losing a parent but Shaun wanted to talk
about Patti's legacy speaking from her
adopted home town of Coeur d'Alene Idaho
Shaun's proud that she helps shed the
stigma of mental illness the more she
opened up the more she shared of her
pain it's very instructive for people
his mid 1980s bipolar diagnosis was it
was a watershed but now she had an a new
identity and a whole new mission whole
new sense of purpose and that was to
share what she had gone through with
other people she often shared those
battles with ET by being so open she
helped countless others I happen to
prefer calling my disorder manic
depression it is known as bipolar
disorder now and if that works for other
people
fine I prefer calling it manic
depression because it sounds like how it
felt
Shaun has set up a fund raiser for the
Patty Duke mental health project which
will continue his mother's campaign of
awareness the thing that gives me such
joy and reverence for her is it above
all else use a warrior